- Alright, y'all. Welcome back!
We've got Jul with us hanging out.
(audience cheering)
Our next guest is one of
the greatest percussionists
of all time, but you already know that,
because you heard her play
with my band on the "KellyOke" earlier
and you just know her
career, she's incredible.
Her new salsa album is
coming out next year,
and the single that I am not gonna mess
up is called, "Bemba Colora", I think.
Drops in January.
I'm gonna ask her to correct
me if I'm wrong. "Colora".
So, everybody, give it up for Sheila E.
(audience cheering)
(upbeat music)
Have a seat.
(audience cheering)
"Bemba Colora"?
- Yes, "Bemba Colora".
- Okay.
- "Bemba Colora".
- Bemba. Bemba.
- It sounds sexier when you say it. Okay.
(Sheila laughing)
But I didn't know this,
but you were on the "Renaissance" album,
Beyonce's album, as well.
Is it "Cuff It"?
- Yeah.
- Is that the one?
- Yeah, yeah. Yeah.
- Yeah.
Did you not know it either till like-
- I did not.
- This is amazing! So what is that story?
- No, because you, like, you text me,
"Hey, play on this song."
And you never know when
something's gonna come out or not.
And I played, recorded with Rafael Saadiq,
'cause he grew up with us.
So we're from the Bay Area, from Oakland.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And so we're always in the studio.
So we're just recording stuff.
And next thing you know,
Beyonce's team comes
to the studio and they like that song.
And so I'm in the park walking my dog
and someone says, they start texting me,
"Congratulations, you're
on the new Beyonce song."
I said, "No, I'm not."
'Cause I didn't, I wasn't
in the studio with her.
You never know.
- You were like,
"No, no, no. You're
thinking of somebody else."
Yeah. You're like, yeah.
- Yeah, and I had no idea.
So I'm walking my dog, more
texts, then I call Rafael.
And I was like, "They're
telling me that I'm on the song
and you produced it.
I don't remember being in the
studio with you on that song."
He said, "No, that's you."
They ended up taking
the portion that we did
and then adding on top of it.
I was like, "Okay, well-
- [Kelly] Okay so-
- "Did I get paid?"
- Yes.
Yes.
- That was the next question.
- That's my firm question.
- That was it.
- Yeah. No, that's incredible though.
So they took what you did
and then created a song outta that.
That's even more of a compliment.
- Yeah. No, it was Rafael.
He wrote the song and I
played on top of that song.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And then they took that point.
But yeah, so I'm on,
that's how I get on things.
- That's incredible.
- I never know.
- But you got your Walk of
Fame star recently. Yeah.
- Yes.
- This is past summer?
- That was incredible.
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] Congratulations.
- Thank you.
- That's so cool.
- [Sheila] Thank you.
- And her and, yeah, this is so cool.
- Thank you.
- Is that where, when
did you first meet Ringo?
When did y'all first meet up?
- I wanna say 2001 or
2003. I can't remember.
But I got the call from-
- [Kelly] But definitely not 2002.
- No, no. No, it wasn't.
It was one, it was an odd number.
(audience laughing)
Man, you are so awesome.
- Amazing.
- Smart-ass.
- Being in New York. Yes.
- But like, definitely not the two.
- Yeah. Not the two.
- Okay. Okay.
- It was odd.
- [Kelly] Okay. It was an odd number.
- Yeah.
Were you excited, like, to meet up
and like, hey, did you
grow up playing, or?
- I have a crazy bucket list.
That was not on my list,
for me to meet Ringo Starr,
let alone play with him.
Like, both of us playing
drums together in his band.
I was tripping out.
And I was the first ever, and
still the only woman playing
in that band in all of his All-Star Band-
- [Kelly] He put All-Star, yeah.
- Yeah. All-Star, and he's still doing it.
And I'm the only Beetle-ette. Thank you.
- That is.
(audience applauding)
You should get a star for
that. I was like, listening.
So you're, I find this incredible,
you told me this before,
but that you've never made a salsa album.
This is your first, like, salsa album.
- Yeah, I've never-
- Which I find incredibly odd.
- Yeah.
- I know. It's weird.
- I mean, my dad, the
legendary Pete Escovedo.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- He, my dad. Yes.
- Yes.
(audience applauding)
- Latin Jazz. That's what I grew up.
That's the foundation of who I am.
- [Kelly] Absolutely.
- And being in the Bay,
all the different music.
- It's just you're a percussionist
and you're so well-known, I just assumed.
- No, but salsa music
is totally different.
It's very strict.
Like, it's something that, I mean,
I think this is the best record
I've ever done in my life.
- What a beautiful thing.
- Yeah.
- I'm like touched by like-
- Yes.
- I have Ruben Blades
singing. He's amazing.
I mean, if people know, yeah.
Thank you. Ruben Blades.
I cried when I've heard the first verse
because it's something that I'll,
it's like if I do a salsa record,
he's gotta be the first one.
Gilberto Santa Rosa sang, Gloria Estefan.
- [Kelly] I love her.
- Debbie Noah. Yeah.
We have so many, yeah.
There's so many amazing people singing-
- [Kelly] That's incredible.
- And performing on this record.
It took me almost two years to do it.
- It's inspiring though
in the sense of like,
man, you already have
this massive a career,
you know, both of you,
like, you don't need
to do anything at this point,
but then you do something
because you just have a desire to do it.
And then it's like some,
it's one of your most proud projects.
That's incredible.
- It's incredible. No, it
really is. I'm so proud.
And it's crazy because taking
that long to do something,
I was gonna try to put it out this year
and it's like, no, this
is not the right time.
- Take out under.
- We have to wait.
Just take out, because
I have another album
out that's already out now.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- A new-
- Girl, I know you're always working.
- I know.
Every time, like, I text,
I'm like, "She is going to Germany."
Apparently, I was like, "All right."
Well, everybody, we need another break.
Look out for Sheila's salsa
album coming next year,
and the single, "Bemba Colora",
which drops in January.
I tried to say it sexy for you.
- You did.
- We've got Ashley Flowers
from the hit podcast,
"Crime Junkie" here next.
We'll be right back.